it's no secret that i am not uh a big
fan of superheroes it's been nearly 24
years since i was 12 and so it has been
nearly 24 years since i was a fan of
superheroes but still the question
remains of all the superheroes which
five are the worst and i may not seem
like the most qualified person to answer
that question i think i'm the most
qualified actually i can be entirely
objective about this and with that in
mind i thought today we would do
something very important and review and
rank the five worst superheroes
we'll go down the list from five to one
we'll start here number five wonder
woman
[Music]
okay
people actually watch this
people watch that on purpose
grown adult men with kids who go to the
theater to watch that you know when i
brought that up before i i've been told
well gal gadot is really hot she's
attractive well of course i want to
watch it get a girlfriend dude like get
married get a wife
you're going to sit and watch a two and
a half hour terrible movie because she's
attractive there's like there's lots of
attributes to attractively go to the
grocery store to see attractive woman
are you gonna sit and watch this
terrible move for that reason okay first
of all
who the hell dresses like that for
trench warfare that's what i'm trying to
understand so that oh there's a war well
hang on let me put my leather leotard on
and she's not impervious to bullets
right
she's not so
just like her little bracelets are
imperviousable so so she's got 20 german
guys firing at her
and none of the bullets hit any part of
her body
except for a couple that she can deflect
in order to block a bullet she'd have to
move her arm so quick that we don't even
see it move and yet she just kind of
casually there's a bullet are they
actually in real life firing slow-motion
bullets at wonder woman is that what's
happening here i've never seen anyone
move that fast the other guys they get
out and they start charging towards the
german guys and but then explicitly the
german guys also get out of they it's
like braveheart they you know that's not
how trench warfare works if you've got
people charging at you you stay in your
trench and you just shoot them all you
mow them all down they decide to get out
and then when that happens wonder woman
like jumps in the air
you know 50 feet and lands in the trench
well then why didn't you do that to
begin with if you had that ability she
starts just kind of casually walking
into the middle of the fire fight and
then realizes oh i can do a super jump
and just end up there this is all to be
expected
for one of the lamest corniest
superheroes to ever be invented
even the name
wonder woman can you imagine in real
life if somebody had superpowers
and then decided they wanted to fight
crime and they made that outfit for
themselves and you asked them what name
they chose and she said oh i thought i'd
go with wonder woman can we workshop
that one a little bit what are wonder
woman's powers anyway she has uh magical
bracelets i guess she has i think she
has a wig right
and um i think she's a van like the
mystery van where's that scooby doo no
she has the jet she has an invisible jet
i'm actually in the lavatory of the
invisible plane
which will be utterly useless against
modern radar technology by the way
so lame corny useless wonder woman
number five let's go to number four
black widow
[Music]
now she should really be higher on the
list i think but there are just too many
lame superheroes to go around so
decisions have to be made black widow
from what i understand has no
superpowers so she's just like she's
just a she's a chick right she's just a
woman what is a woman she's scarlett
johansson is is black widow and scarlett
johansson is five foot three inches tall
and like 90 pounds and we're supposed to
believe that this skinny little female
with no special magical powers
is going around beating the hell out of
dudes three times their size all these
goons are standard none of them are
armed they won't just pull out a gun and
just shoot her in the head
end of storyline and i get this is
fiction but you might as well have a
character who is a baby have stewie
griffin show up and just make him one of
your avengers oh i feel as invincible as
superman i can't take it seriously you
know in the past public schools were
simply neglecting foundational subjects
like math english science and history
many looked the other way now we see
that woke teachers are proudly bragging
on social media about pushing radical
sometimes sexually charged propaganda on
kids as young as five or even younger
than that there are even reports of
teachers secretly hosting drag shows for
students without the consent of parents
all with the blessing of unions and some
members of congress if you want a real
education for your child then you need
freedom project academy they've
perfected live online learning for more
than a decade freedom project academy is
built on judeo-christian values and
classical curriculum they're dedicated
to providing mastery of subject matter
not leftist propaganda go to
freedomforschool.com that's
freedomforschool.com to request your
free information packet today think
about this what is a college degree
worth if the average public school
graduate can only read and write at a
7th grade level that's how bad it is so
go to freedomforschool.com that's
freedomforschool.com and get your child
enrolled at freedom project academy
today before spots fill up that's
freedomforschool.comfreedomforschool.com
so black widow is uh number four now
we'll go to number three
with she-hulk i just want to be a normal
anonymous lawyer can you tell us where
she-hulk is jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
[Music]
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
okay now
as far as the film itself and i know i'm
kind of conflating like i'm ranking the
films and also the characters i'm
complaining to but whatever we're just
gonna go with it the cgi is on the level
of
the 1970s hulk it's about on that level
we've come full circle actually
and this is just a woman in green makeup
this looks like if a high school put on
a stage production of shrek that's kind
of what it would look like there
and the hulk though
as a character is dumb enough he's the
superhero that any eight-year-old could
make up and pretty much every
eight-year-old has made up the hulk
independently before discovering that
the hulk exists he's really strong
and uh
like really really strong
anything else about him uh he's green
he's a strong green guy every movie with
the hulk that's the question that
they're asking you to
contemplate what if there was a strong
green guy who existed and you just watch
and you see okay this is what would
happen so that's dumb enough
but then you take him and give him a sex
change and it's even worse you have a
female hulk what are we gonna call her
um
she-hulk let's call her not very
progressive i mean in this day and age
in the year 2022
you're gonna put pronouns in front of a
hulk and you're just going with she what
about a non-binary hole can we get a
they hulk yet another problem uh what do
we all know number two
is
some superhero called captain marvel
[Music]
surprised
is
[Music]
you knew all along
is that why we never hung out no i just
never liked you
[Applause]
i feel concussed i feel brain damaged
watching this
you know you really it's one of those
things you do get dumber did anybody
watch this maybe no one watched this one
i don't know i hope nobody did they
really played i'm just a girl during
that scene they really did that did we
did we put that in or is that in the
movie itself oh it's in the movie they
put that in the movie they might as well
have her shout girl power while she's
like she does a she does a drop kick and
check girl power and what are captain
marvel's powers exactly besides girl
power she has super strength super speed
super agility and super durability she
also has healing powers and she can fly
at the speed of sound and she can shoot
magical laser light beams out of her
hands they just decided she can do
everything which is just as lazy as
giving her no powers and just as boring
as stanley in fact it's if anything more
boring one of my fundamental problems
with these superhero films is that
there's no tension at all these are
people who are indestructible they can
do anything even if something bad
somehow does happen now with the marvel
movies we're introducing other universes
so there's multiple so we just you know
you could kill somebody off and just
replace them there's an infinite number
of of spider-man just replace what's the
point of any of this
there's no tension here there's no
suspense at all zero anyway what we're
talking about oh captain marvel uh not
to mention the distribution of powers
among all these heroes and villains is
so uneven that it just it doesn't make
any sense
when they all fight each other so you've
got like a superhero with super strength
who can fly faster than a sound wave and
incinerate you with light beams out of
her eyes or whatever and she's somehow
drawn into a stalemate against
some other character who learned karate
in fifth grade one minute someone has is
a god and has all the powers in the
world next minute if the scene requires
him to just be sort of a normal dude
then that's what he is doesn't make any
sense and i'm trying not to hold brie
larson against captain marvel brie
larson is insufferable but that's not
the character's fault is that like a
personal attack or something
my problem with the character is that
she's boring pointless and lazy finally
this has gone on way longer than it
should or i ever thought it would we'll
go to number one and that is uh
batwoman
[Music]
[Music]
uh so this is on the cw i think so at
least at least in this case
nobody is watching it so i can at least
say that so that's that's the good thing
so that's bat woman i think and batwoman
is a lesbian no big surprise there what
is a lesbian the problem with batwoman
is very similar to the black widow
problem because she has no superpowers
no special abilities and yet i'm
supposed to take her seriously as this
physically imposing presence somebody
who beats up bad guys and that doesn't
work because there just there has to be
a certain intimidation factor
for the character to work and no one
you're looking at this chick
nobody's
intimidated and this is worse for
batwoman because you have batman
to compare her to
and every time batwoman is on screen
you're just thinking how much better it
would be if it was batman and there's
certainly never a time when as a victim
you'd prefer to have bat woman come save
you you know i'd rather have robin robin
they said you there's another member of
the lgbt community but you'd rather have
him show up what she lacks in uh uh in
physical ability i guess she makes up
for in wokeness so she is in fact the
worst superhero and the fact that all
five of the worst ones are women
it's not my fault okay i didn't plan it
that way it's just i didn't i didn't i
didn't make this list i simply observed
it it was written in the stars and i
it's an objective reality don't blame me
blame the people who came up with this
absolute nonsense
well those were a bunch of lame
superheroes but if you don't want to be
lame and useless yourself like all these
female superheroes then make sure you
hit that like button hulk smash that
notification bell
annihilate that subscribe button
and be a true
superhero
[Music]